tratando de recuperar el control después
de la evasión carcelaria más grande y
mortífera de haití en una década las
autoridades están recorriendo el país en
busca de cientos de fugitivos el jueves
más de 400 reclusos lograron huir de la
cárcel y 787 que tenía casi el doble de
su capacidad de reclusos antes del
incidente había mil 542 personas en la
prisión del quad de ugt después de los
controles realizados hoy vemos mil 125
presos que están en prisión entre los
fugitivos que la policía logró localizar
se encontraba uno de los principales
líderes de pandillas en haití en el
josep el más buscado por las autoridades
del país hasta su arresto en 2019 bajo
cargos que incluían violación secuestro
y homicidio
josep ya había intentado escapar en
julio pero esta vez fue detectado en un
puesto de control y murió tras un
tiroteo con la policía durante la fuga
otros presos fueron asesinados al igual
que varios transeúntes y el director de
la penitenciaría en twitter el
presidente de jouvenel moix condenó el
hecho y le pidió a la policía usar todas
las medidas necesarias esta no es la
primera vez que los reclusos escapan de
las cárceles de haití en 2014 de la
misma prisión construida con
de canadá se escaparon 300 condenados
antes de eso durante el devastador
terremoto en haití en 2010 más de 4000
prisioneros huyeron en el caos que
siguió al desastre natural